[Müzik]
Eve gelirdim hızlıca çantamı böyle
fırlatırdım işte hemen yapacağım ödevler
ne varsa böyle yarına yapılacak işte
15-20 dakikada onları bir çırpıda böyle
hızla bitirirdim Kendimi dışarı atardım
ya işte bir modern dans ya da halk
oyunları çalışmasına işte ne bileyim
okul takımının bir antrenmanı vardır
mutlaka bir şey vardı yani okul dışı
zamanlarda işte Hiç olmadı mahallede bir
parkımız var bizim orada giderdik böyle
Akşam yemeğine kadar işte biliyorsunuz
yani Muhtemelen o zamanları yaşayan
arkadaşlarım vardı aranızda böyle
terleyene kadar Terden domates Ee gibi
kızarana kadar maçlar yapardık şanslı
hissediyorum Yani o zamanları
yakalayabildiğim için
okul yaşantısı böyle geçti işte ilkokul
lise ve tiyatro hayatında çok ön
plandaydı o arada tabii ki bahsetmeyi
unuttuğum şey iki buçuk yaşında bu okuma
yazma hadiseleri falan olurken bir
yandan da oynayacak bir melodikayla
işte tanışıyor karşılaşıyorum ve onu
çalmaya başlıyorum Duyduğum her şeyi
çalmaya başlamış bunu fark edince
Bizimkiler bana bir org alıyorlar küçük
bir org böyle o ordulardan olanlar
vardır diye düşünüyorum varsa şöyle
elleriniz kaldırabilirsiniz üstünde
böyle davul sesi sarı sarı böyle işte
[Müzik]
onunla bu sefer bütün onun imkanlarını
sömürdüm Ben ardından başka bir bir
büyük org geldi Onun da bütün imkanları
bitti işte 7 yaşındaki lise konusunda
şarkı söylemeye başladım orada kendi
kendime notu Okumayı Öğrendim şefimiz
vardı işte melodi herkes güzelce
ezberleyebilsin falan diye 15-20 kere
çalardı 7'den 70'e diyebiliyoruz ben 7
yaşındaydım
70 yaşında teyzelerimiz vardı yani o
konuda öyle söyleyeyim 15-20 kişilik bir
topluluk düşünün ve işte orada elimdeki
kağıtlarla ilgilenmeye başladıkça Ben
notalara fonksiyonlarında Tek Tek İşte
Aa tizde işte pesleşti geri döndük
vesaire gibi çözdüm ve kendi kendime not
Okumayı Öğrendim O internet size yavaş
yavaş hayatımıza girdi İnternetten
indirdiğim notalar oldu notalarla Böyle
işte Ne çok dağınık Klavyede böyle
piyano parçaları çalmaya çalıştım falan
iki elle çalındığını keşfettim bu
aletimi bir anda böyle bir müzik
yaşantısı kendi kendine ilerliyor
Aslında bu anlattığım şeylerin yanında
hiçbir zaman çok ön planda değil ama hep
var bize de tiyatro dediğim gibi çok
hayatında önemli bir yeri vardır Hatta
ne okuyacağımı hiç bilmiyordum ama
lisede sanıyorum sınava kadar tek böyle
aklıma gelen şey acaba tiyatro okusandır
dramatoloji 90 diye düşünüyorum seçmedi
bir müzik grubumuzda vardı Lisede işte
Hem vokal yapıyorum Hem klavye çalıyorum
gitar böyle kendi kendine çalmayı
öğrenmişim onu çalıyorum vesaire
yarışmalara festivallere katılıyoruz
bunlardan bir tanesi de Radyo
boğaziçi'nin düzenledim Battle ben diye
önemli bir amatör müzik grupları
yarışması zamanında Manga Gripin gibi
grupların birinci olup da böyle
kariyerlerinde başladı türden bir
yarışma
Neyse biz lise grubumuzla Bu yarışmaya
başvurduk Finale kaldık müthiş çığlıklar
falan müthiş bir sevinç 8 grup finalde
işte final günü üniversiteye gittik ilk
kez Boğaziçi Üniversitesini görüyorum
hep aklımda zaten olsun dersinde okumak
var işte sınavdan önce bir kere görme
şansım oldu kenarda duruyoruz böyle işte
sabah 10.30 gibi saat içerisinde
bekliyoruz işte enstrümanlar böyle
yaslanmışız biraz kurbanlık koyun gibi
bekliyoruz Çünkü 25-30 yaşında hatta 40
yaşlarında insanlar var Tüm türkiye'ye
açık bir şey bir yarışma yani sağlam bir
yarışma birisi dayanarak geldi yanımıza
dedi ki ya çocuklar siz ne yapıyorsunuz
burada sizde mi finalesiniz Yoksa böyle
hani şaşkınlıkla hayretle Biz de Evet
büyük başarı başımıza okşama falan böyle
bir daha görmedik sonra o abi akşam o
yarışmada Biz birinci olduk öyle falan
orada her şey yakışıklandı ve böyle çok
önemli bir anlık Tabii hayatımızda boğaz
İki seçenek vardı psikoloji ve matematik
hangisinde derinleşebilirim diye
düşündüm bu İki seçeneğin arasından
matematik seçtim başladım okumaya TRT
İstanbul radyosu çok sesli gençlik
konusunda şarkı söylemeye başladım bir
yandan üniversit
enin korolarının olduğu
onlardan bir tanesinin dinletisine denk
geldi tanışma yeteneklerinde işte caz
konusuydu yine 15-20 kişilik böyle bir
topluluk çok güzel bir repertuar var
bende heveslendim ben de söylemek
istiyorum dedi hep korolarda şarkı
söyleyen bir çocuk olarak işte
sınavlarına girdim geçtim başladı
söylemeye ve 2 yıl kadar o zamanki
şefimiz cihandan asistanlığına yaptı
korodu aslında bir yandan şarkı
söylerken ve böyle çok gevşek de
hazırlık ya da geçiriyorum isteyerek
bilerek isteyerek
üniversiteyi ne kadar uzun otursam o
kadar iyi olur diye düşünüyordum o kadar
fazla düşündüm ki demek ki aslında hala
öğrenciyim arkadaşlar
Üniversitesinde Müzik Bölümü yok yani
biliyorsunuzdur bir kısmınız Dolayısıyla
Aslında bu tamamen bir öğrenci akbilet
Ben Herkes başka bölümlerde okuyor Bir
profesyonel bir durum yok yani amatör
bir etkinlik Tamam dedim ben de
mutlulukla Tabii ki Gurur duyarak kabul
ettim ama dedim senden önce seninle
rızanı alarak bir şey yapmak istiyorum
sıfırdan bir seçme yapmak istiyorum
dedim ben bu insanlara işte bak çok laf
söylerler çok zorlukla karşılaşacaksın
vesaire Hani
Emin misin bunu yapmaya dedi Ben dedim
ki başka türlü yapamam Çünkü bu benim
huyum Hani bahsettiğim ya Bir şeyi
yaparken en iyisi olsun layıkıyla yapmak
hakkını vererek yapmak hep bana keyif
vermiştir O yüzden de şunu söylerim Hiç
hobim bu oldu diyemem Benden hiç o gün
olamadım yani işte o modern dans'tan
bahsedeyim Mesela işte halk oyunları
vesaire tiyatro yazar Ee aslında bir
hobim olsa iyi olurmuş diyorum ama bir
yandan da hobi gözüyle bakmadığım için
Salt ve o bir gözüyle bakmadığım için
yaptığım her şeyden aslında çok şey
kazandığımı fark ettim baktığımda o
videoda Aslında gördüğünüz şeylerin
içinde hepsi var sahneye baktığınız
zaman şu anki Aslında anlatımda da var
Yani bunlar
dolayısıyla bir sorumluluk bana
verildiği zaman ama en iyisi olacak
tabii ki ona da öyle yaklaşınca Cihan
Hani dedi ki tamam dedi Ben senin her
zaman destekçinin yanındayım ben yaptım
gerçekten sıfırdan bir seçme işte 9 kişi
başladı Bende Korona içindeyim
yönetmiyorum kimseyi o sırada beraber
çalışmaya başladık
ilk dönem Yani bir buçuk iki aylık
maksimum dönemde o zamana kadar
yapılmamış derecede böyle bir sağlam bir
çalışma ve ardından ilk performansınız
gerçekten de o söylenen laflar Hani niye
baştan seçme yapılıyor yeni eski köye
yeni adet mi geliyor vesaire şeyler bir
noktada o performansından sonra
hakikaten ha
şey var demek ki deyim böyle yanıma bir
arkadaşım diye söylemiştim unutmuyorum
Ya abi dedi ben tamam farklı bir şey
olacağını düşünüyorum ama itiraf edeyim
bu kadarını beklemiyordum dedi
Ben de teşekkür ettim gülümsedim geçtim
ve o bir yıl iki yıl üç yıl dört yıl
kadar üniversite çatısı altında biz
gerçekten çok fazla şey yaptık 3 yılımız
adaylık yanımızda o sürede çok önemli
bir Akabe yarışmasına
katıldık 2003 diploma kazandı yine aynı
biz böyle
18-19-20 yaşlarında Gençler işte 6
profesyonel albümünü çıkarıp bize imzalı
hediye eden gruplar falan var onlarla
yarışıyoruz
müthiş bir vizyon getirdi Tabii ki bir
sonraki yıl bir orkestramız oldu bu
sefer ben orada çalıyorum yine müzik
direktörüyüm ama işte Farklı stillerde
daha çok cihaz ve süreleri söylüyoruz
sonraki yıl Çin'e gitmeye karar verdik
dünya kova olimpiyatlarına kimse
gidemezsiniz dedi çünkü çok büyük bir
bütçe var 20 kişilik bir topluluğuz işte
19-20 kişilik bir oda koruması olmuş ben
ilk kez sahnede yönetmeye başlamışım
işte ben de 22 yaşındayım yani Bu arada
derken son saniye kadar direnip asla
vazgeçmeyip böyle Öz etleyeyim ben o
süreçte çok uzun bir süre içerisinde ama
böyle herkesin kafasında herkese düşmek
üzereyken yani takım liderleri proje
yönetenler bu dediğim şey çok daha iyi
anlayacaklar ya işte Öğretmen arkadaşlar
var burada hani size başımızın dik
tutmak zorundasınız eleştirelim hayatına
böyle geç Çünkü bir rahat indi herkes
zaten dağılmaya çok müsait bütün
imkansızlıklar önümüzde engellerimizle
yapmayın diyor Herkes bunu yani Türkiye
bunu Aslında sanat Yapmayın bu ülkede
diyor size dile gelse Bunu söyleyecek
yani Ama Israrla vazgeçmeden biz o
bütçeyi toparladık bir şekilde rektör
hocamızın bir yolunu kesti falan filan
Çin'e gittik
90 ülkeden işte 300 Koruluk katıldı 400
Korona katıldı çok devasa bir
organizasyon bir ikincilik iki üçüncülük
ödülü kazandık Türkiye'ye döndük tabi
müthiş birisi yan yana rüyalar
tarafından insanlarla tanışmışız bir
sonraki Avusturya'ya gitmek istiyoruz
yine paramız yok ne yapacağız ne
edeceğiz 35 kişilik bir kadro olmuş
dünya şampiyonasına Hazırlanıyoruz böyle
o sezon 30-40 tane konser yapmışız
Türkiye'deki 12 olmuş farklı şehirde
üniversitelerden davetler almışız müthiş
yoğun bir tatminenin ortasında ne
yapalım Ne yapalım Para yok para
bulmamız lazım sponsor bulmamız lazım
diye Az önce izlediğiniz videonun
başındaki net pro videosu çıktı ortaya o
videoyu gören var mı hiç Metro videosu
ile daha önce karşılaşan O çok kişi
süper Yani aslında Türkiye'de çok sesli
Kor uyucu ile suç oldu o video ile
birlikte
Biz dünya şampiyonasına o videoluk
sayesinde sponsorumuzu bulduk dünya
şampiyonasına katılabildik ve çok zor
bir süreç içinde üniversiteden ayrılmak
zorunda kaldık tam o süreçte Ee ve iki
bina şampiyonluk kazanıp Türkiye'ye geri
döndük
2012'de İtalya Amerika Macaristan'da çok
önemli festivallere davetler aldık biri
korol olimpiyatlarıydı yine yine paramız
yok son dakika bir sponsorluk desteği
ihtimali de oldu çok iyi gidiyorlar Her
şey bir anda pat diye işte mali bir kriz
manevi kriz sebebiyle malesef Size
destek Olamayacağız haberiyle yine
yıkılmak üzere iken
yine bir Çılgınlık yapıp yerini
söylemişti 100 bin Euro'luk totalde bir
borcumun altına girerek Yani aslında bir
kişi giriyor orijinalde Teknik olarak
yani bir imza varsa o benim imzalarım 24
yaşında bir genç olarak 100.000 Euro
borcuna imza atar mıydınız şu anda bir
koro yarışmasına gideceksiniz mesela
düşün
ün
buralara gittik altın madalyalar
birincilikler ve dünyanın en önemli
festivallerinden Koru müziğini Zirvesi
olarak gösterilen çok önemli bir
Festival dahil olmak üzere O risk
sayesinde de aslında davetler almaya ama
o 100.000 Euro borcu şimdi zaten
neredeyse herhalde
2 milyon lira değil mi Evet harika olmuş
o borcu Biz beş yılda kapatabildik
arkadaşlar
Ama onun üzerine tabii ki yolunuz Çok
açıldı ve
2014'te Boğaziçi gençlik konusudur
2016'da Magnum topluluğunu kurduk
dünyanın en prestijli festivallerinde
Türkiye'yi kendi müziğimizi kültürümüzü
temsil etme şansımız oldu gururla
başarıyla
ve şu an Geldiğimiz noktada bünyesindeki
8 farklı toplulukta Belki 1000'e yakın
amatör aktif Koru şarkıcısı bulunduran
kocaman bir aile olduğunu milyonlarca
seveni takipçisi olan toplumsal
konularda sesini çıkarmaktan hiçbir yeri
durmayan ve her gün gerçekten çok zor
zamanlarında insanlara ilham olabilen
çok büyük bir aile koruhane kültürlerin
sesi gibi projelerle Aslında tüm Türkiye
Ekonomi üzerine istediklerime devam eden
müthiş bir özveri ile tek destekçimiz
Yücel kültürü ve aklımızda provama
mekanımızı sağlıyor Onun dışında kim
maddi destekçimiz Yok ya 9 yıldır
kendi çabasıyla ki ben dahil 4 kişilik
yönetim kurulumu tamamen kömürlü
çalışıyoruz burada para kazanmıyoruz
hala
bütün bunları yaparak kocaman bir aile
olduk ismine madhuba ve Boğaziçi Caz
Korusu ailesidir Peki bunları yaptık Ben
matematiği bıraktım Bütün bunları
anlatırken onları geçtim İşte yıldızda
müzik okumaya başladım 1 yıl sonra orayı
bıraktım Mimar Sinan Güzel Sanatlar
Üniversitesi Devlet Konservatuarı
kompozisyon bölümü 1 yıl sonra Orayı da
bıraktım Sonra geri döndüm vesaire
derken ben hala şu an pandemi döneminde
bıraktığım eğitimime devam etme yolunda
lisans 3 öğrencisi olarak bir yandan da
okula gidiyor Yani bugün dersimi
asıyorum buraya gelmek için orkestra
şefi okuyorum bütün bunları yapıyoruz
Acaba niye yapıyoruz bu ısrar niye bana
soruyorlar Yani sen niye hala buradasın
Türkiye'de bunu niye bu kadar devam
ettiriyorsun yurt dışına gitsen bunları
daha rahat yapmaz mısın diye hep
sorarlardı 6 yıl önceden bir kesit
paylaşacağım
[Müzik]
diyenler var
çok işim var Burada sadece
yurt dışına gitmek Tabii ki anlaşılır
kapılar açan bir şey Orada yaşamak bu
bizi yolda kira ödemek bütün imkanlar
çok daha yüksek Bütün bunlara rağmen
bütün bunları farkında değilken niye
buradasın diyenler için de şunu söylüyor
olabilir
im
birilerinin burada kalması gerekiyor Bu
sözün arkasında durmak çok
zorlaştırdığını ama yani işte Son
zamanlarda 6 yıl önce söylediğim için
şimdi soruyorlar Hala mı diye Evet hala
doğru söz birilerinin mutlaka burada
olması gerekiyor çünkü hepimiz gidersek
aslında gitmek değildi gitmek dönmek
beslenmek beslemek bundan bahsediyorum
ama buranın bize çok ihtiyacı var hatta
şu anda en çok ihtiyacı olan dönemdeyiz
Bence biz de bunu koro müziğiyle yapmaya
çalışıyoruz Çünkü konu müziği Türkiye
için ve dünya için çok çok önemli
Arkadaşlar neden önemli Biz koruyucusu
yaparken
çok şey öğreniyoruz Aslında hayalini
kurduğumuz huzur ve barış içinde yaşamak
dediğin şey var ya onu asla koruma bizi
yaparken zaten bizzat deneyebiliyoruz
Nasıl oluyor bu birbirimizi daha fazla
dinlemeyi öğreniyoruz dolayısıyla daha
iyi anlıyoruz birbirimize Ee
yardımlaşmayı dayanışmayı paylaşmayı
sevgiyi öğreniyoruz koruma Bir şeyi
yaparken ve farklılıklarımızı diğer
dezavantaj değil Biraz zenginlik olarak
görmeye ve bu farklı renklerin
oluşturduğu harmandan
keyif almayı öğreniyoruz tam o yüzden
Diyoruz ki Türkiye'nin her yerinde
korolarımız çoğalsın çocuklarımız
gençlerimiz çok sesli konularda şarkı
söyleyerek yetişsinler ve az önce
bahsettiğim sevgiyi paylaşmayı
dayanışmayı bu İnsanı değerleri
öğrenerek o değerlerle yoğrularak
birlikte bir şey yapmadım keyfiyle
yetişsinler de işte o gençlerin
oluşturacağı toplumlar o zaman dünyaya
çok daha farklı bakacaktır şimdi olduğu
gibi maalesef aylardır
gözümüzün önünde olan savaşlardan
kavgalardan değil de işte o zaman aşktan
sevgiden barıştan ve kardeşlikten
bahsedeceğimiz günler gelecek ve bunda
hep birlikte başaracağız buna inanıyorum